well we've got a lot of clouds in town
this morning look at that pretty color
in the sky these are clouds all ahead of
that next storm that's pounding
California right now 48 degrees humidity
that's over 60 almost 70 percent now in
dew points that are almost up to 40. so
air is getting a little more saturated
and we'll continue that through the day
we're nearly 10 degrees warmer this
morning than we were yesterday at this
hour Sunrise officially 6 40 52 and
sunset at 444. been windy up in Western
Nevada ely's had some wind so is uh have
our local mountains spring mountains
have been somewhat windy as well 53 and
prompt 30's for Indian Springs 40s for
Reno right now and low 40s for Mesquite
rain is on the way in fact watching a
few little very light showers trying to
develop over Northeast Clark County
along I-15 Northeast to the valley and
snow across parts of I-15 up into
Southwest Utah again it's all part of
that next atmospheric River storm that's
pounding California flooding rains power
outages is has just been so much in fact
Avalanche warnings now throughout the
Sierra with so much heavy snow the low
is still out to sea there is a cold
front with this system that as it passes
through tomorrow could bring
thunderstorms with lightning and strong
Gusty winds with it so again so many
watches warnings advisories for snow
rain a Relentless rain and wind across
Nevada we have a wind advisory really
for the southern two-thirds almost all
of the state wind advisory for Clark
County starts Tuesday at noon until 7 pm
and we also have winter storm warnings
issued again for our mountains those
actually start at 4 P.M today until 10
p.m Tuesday heavy snow anticipated in
the higher elevations of the spring
mountains 60 degrees for our afternoon
about a 30 percent chance of showers
rain chances increase tonight into
Tuesday and again looking also for a
chance of thunderstorms tomorrow so
tomorrow should be the big rain maker
and heavy snow maker for us we'll look
for Sunshine Wednesday and more rain
returning again with another storm on
Sunday